bonsoir à toutes et à tous bonne année
heureux de vous retrouver en direct pour
un nouvel numéro de sens public vous
êtes de plus en plus nombreux nombreuses
à répondre au rendez-vous tous les jours
du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h merci de
votre fidélité on va continuer de donner
du sens à l'actualité prendre du recul
aussi pour tenter de comprendre le plus
finement possible les crises que nous
traversons voici le sommaire de ce 9
janvier le palais présidentiel le
Congrès la Cour suprême ce sont les
lieux du pouvoir que les bolsonaris sont
pris d'assaut hier au Brésil plus de 300
personnes arrêtées les forces de l'ordre
ont repris le contrôle le président Lula
s'est rendu sur place sans pouvoir
est-il fragile comment l'armée pourrait
réagir quelle similitude avec l'assaut
du Capitole à Washington il y a deux ans
nos experts répondant à ces questions et
à d'autres dans une minute et puis pour
notre second débat c'est un thème
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour que je vous propose avec cette
question la France souffrent-elles d'une
épidémie de flemme une étude de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès l'affirmait il y a
deux mois repli sur soi fatigue perte de
sens et si cette lassitude était le
signal d'un équilibre à réinventer c'est
ce que dit Benoît Hamon dans l'Antiquité
on n'avait pas le même ordre de valeur
le temps qui était le temps de l'amitié
le temps du savoir le temps de la
sagesse le temps qui n'était pas passé à
travailler pour vivre était en valeur
plus importante que le temps qu'on
passait à travailler donc il y a dans
l'histoire de l'Occident ça pas toujours
été le travail d'abord et le reste
ensuite
le droit à la paresse contre la valeur
travail ne ratez pas notre débat dans
trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord donc
16 heures ou le pouvoir du président
Lula à vacillé à Brasilia avec Cécile si
des bâtiments saccagés des œuvres d'art
endommagées au lendemain de la prise
d'assaut de plusieurs institutions par
les partisans de jaillir bolsonaro ce
ministre brésilien découvre le chaos
dans son bureau situé dans le palais
présidentiel
comme vous pouvez le voir tout a été
détruit regardez ça regardez cet écran
un acte criminel a été commis ici c'est
révoltant toute l'après-midi hier une
foule de manifestants vêtue de jaune et
de verre partisan de l'ancien président
ont envahi le Congrès la Cour suprême et
le palais présidentiel pour protester
contre l'élection de Lula
je participe à cette manifestation
totalement Pacifique parce que je ne
suis pas d'accord avec tous les vols de
Lula on veut de nouvelles élections des
urnes propres on ne pense pas que ce
processus était démocratique il y a
plusieurs indications qu'il y a eu
fraude qu'il y a eu corruption
finalement délogés par la police après
plusieurs heures 300 personnes ont été
arrêtées ce matin les rues de Brasilia
ont retrouvé le calme et le président
Lula de retour au palais présidentiel
désormais sous contrôle a condamné cette
invasion et promis la punition des
participants
ce sont de véritables vandales qui
détruisent tout sur leur passage nous
pensons qu'il y a eu un manque de
sécurité et je tiens à vous dire que
tous ceux qui ont fait ça seront
retrouvés et punis
les dirigeants du monde entier ont
condamné ses actions de son côté manuel
Macron assure le soutien d'effectif de
la France à Lula et appelle au respect
des institutions démocratiques au Brésil
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce premier débat Hugo
paletta bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sociologue maître de conférences à
l'Université de Lille actuellement en
délégation à l'inné de l'Institut
national d'études démographique et puis
je cite votre livre la nouvelle
internationale fasciste qui est publiée
aux éditions textuelles John carlossuma
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi ancien
chargé de communication de Lula pendant
deux de ses campagnes électorales et
vous êtes chercheur à l'École des hautes
études en sciences sociales Anne de Zine
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
professeur de l'Universités juriste
auteur de ce livre les États-Unis et la
démocratie publiée aux éditions
l'Harmattan évidemment en voilà et on va
et on va faire le parallèle avec ce qui
s'est passé au Capitole comment ne pas
le faire Matthieu croissanto Victorius
politique bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à
vous heureux de vous retrouver question
assez simple peut-être que la réponse
est complexe pour pour démarrer est-ce
que c'était prévisible Hugo à l'étage
commence avec vous oui alors pour au
moins de raison il y a toute une vague
de mobilisation factueuse d'extrême
droite en tout cas qui sont travaillés
par l'extrême droite au plan mondial on
parle du Capitole bon mais il y a eu
également l'Allemagne en 2020 au bout de
des au terme d'une manifestation qui
avait rassemblé plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes contre le port du
masque obligatoire on a vu la tentative
d'invasion du Bundestag et en Italie en
2021 une manifestation Antipas qui avait
ou une partie des manifestants avez
voulu investir le palais ou siège le
gouvernement et qui finalement s'était
rabattu sur le siège du principal
syndicat italien assez Gilles et avait
tout saccagé donc on est à 4
mobilisations factueuses en potentiel de
Brasilia aujourd'hui et celle du capital
et l'autre raison c'est que pour
laquelle c'était absolument prévisible
et mais d'ailleurs je pense que une
grande partie de la gauche brésienne le
disait depuis des semaines sinon des
mois sinon même d'ailleurs depuis un an
ou deux c'est que bolsonaro a chauffé à
blanc sa base sociale sa base militante
pendant des mois pendant même en réalité
depuis deux ans y compris contre le
tribunal le Tribunal suprême et donc ce
qui s'est passé là et d'une certaine
manière dans la continuité de à sa base
mi-temps à se mobiliser et qui avait
déjà donné lieu après l'élection de Lula
fin octobre à des barrages routiers des
rassemblements devant des casernes à
plan un coup d'État militaire etc donc
c'était effectivement absolument
prévisible on va y revenir un deuxième
vous voyez réagir il y avait des signaux
quand même on parle souvent de signaux
fun on peut le dire aussi des signaux
mais moi je vois des différences entre
ce qui s'est passé en Europe qui est
plutôt anti masque et ce qui s'est passé
au Brésil aux États-Unis et à la limite
dans d'autres pays d'Amérique latine le
Chili par exemple qui là c'est vraiment
le mouvement populiste le rejet des
institutions etc il y a un point commun
quand même dans le Brésil les États-Unis
c'est ce message de l'élection volée qui
est martelé pendant des mois avant les
élections pendant les élections après
les résultats etc pour amener toute
cette population a refusé les résultats
des élections et quant à la
prévisibilité oui on ne voyait bien dans
les réseaux sociaux alors aux États-Unis
c'était dirigé par Trump qui disait
venez le 6 janvier à Washington c'est un
peu moins visible mais ça je parle sous
le contrôle du côté
du Brésil mais il y a ces côtés là parmi
il y a d'autres États d'autres points
communs mais il y a une grande
différence entre le Brésil et les
États-Unis c'est que du côté américain
ça a eu lieu le 6 janvier pour bloquer
la certification des élections donc il
était encore temps de faire quelque
chose
du côté brésilien c'est aposteriori
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a plus de
solution pseudo constitutionnelle comme
dans le cas des américains où il se man
avaient inventé une théorie ou le
vice-président pouvait changer etc là en
fait ce que demande les insurgés moi je
les appelle les insurgés ceux qui ont
pris d'assaut tous ces monuments c'est
en fait à l'armée d'intervenir donc ça
c'est une différence importante ça
pousse beaucoup des thèmes c'est très
bien parce que moi j'aime bien que les
premières interventions posent comme ça
différents thèmes du du débat notamment
le rôle de l'armée on y reviendra ce
comparatif avec le Capitole on y
reviendra évidemment longuement mais Jam
carlosuma est-ce que vous qui connaissez
bien le Brésil je le rappelle que vous
avez accompagné Lola dans l'ordre de
deux campagnes électorales vous aviez
vous des retours de la gauche
brésilienne du nouveau pouvoir de ce
risque finalement de ce danger d'une
insurrection je sais pas quel terme
employer et oui comment on dit les
collègues avant un mois et en fait on
attendait quelque chose on serait pas
exactement quoi mais on attendait
quelque chose et je vous rappelle qu'il
est ça pas fait les Yunes des journaux
mais les 12 décembre que c'était le jour
quand Lula était nommé officiellement
président il avait eu un épisode pas de
cette magnitude pas mais il avait un
épisode aussi de tourisme urbains si on
veut sauver il y a eu
ils ont pris la salle
la base de la police fédérale à Brasilia
le même genre qu'il y a on fait tout
cette invasion de la place de trois
pouvoirs à Brasilia et donc ça c'était à
l'époque un peu minimisé bon sera
quelque chose ça va terminer et
toute la situation par portée en théorie
pour être par paraître un peu contrôler
parce ok les premières janvier ou l'a
été en fait il a eu l'investiture en
fait populaire avec sa centaine
milliards de personnes à Brasilia mais
cette mobilisation de cette
idée cette base facile qu'il y a il faut
le rappeler les choses qu'on leur nom
c'est le extrême droite radicale sont
des faciles comme l'a dit hier Lula en
fait dans son conférence de presse ils
ont été là qui organisaient quelque
chose et là la sensation que j'ai en
parlant avec un peu de gens à Brasilia
et au Brésil aujourd'hui c'est que et il
y a eu une erreur ils ont sous-estimé
les risques ont pensé que la situation
était presque qui se résoudre toute
seule et donc ils n'ont pas pris des
mesures plus énergiques qu'on a fait et
faire dégager avec la force tout cet
énorme campement de des gens qui étaient
bons campés d'avant la question de la
responsabilité de la police de l'État à
Brasilia on va on va y revenir
pourquoi la Cour suprême c'est une des
questions je me suis posé moi ce matin
c'était devenu un symbole oui pour les
bolsonaristes
la Cour suprême surtout un jour j'ai la
Cour suprême qui s'appelle Alexandre
Alexandre de Mores et il ils ont été à
faire les bâloires la ligne de défense
de la démocratie brésilienne pendant
tout ces périodes comme on disait la
collègue avant ou après les beaux
scénaristes ont rejeté les résultats
électoral et eux a fait pour tout je
veux pas expliquer que ça marche tous
les les jours c'est là-bas mais ils ont
validé l'élection et ils ont tenu la
sélection ils ont tenu malgré les
pressions des beaux scénaristes ils ont
aussi fait des choses très concrètes
pour arrêter des campagnes de 10 une
formation sur les réseaux sociaux des
financements illégaux enfin ils ont ils
ont eu un rôle essentiel pour défendre
des solutions démocratiques donc sont
devenus les a fait cible des cibles on
l'a compris de des insurgés
on a vu dans le sujet de Cécile section
en ouverture de ce de cette émission les
images du bureau saccagé du ministre
brésilien des communications je vous
propose d'écouter une autre réaction de
Paolo
ce
que nous voulons souligner c'est que
pour nous ce qui s'est passé ici n'est
pas un acte contre le pouvoir exécutif
mais c'est une attaque contre la
démocratie et contre la Constitution
fédérale il s'agissait d'une tentative
de coup d'État qui n'a pas eu lieu
est-ce que vous employez ce terme de
tentative de coup d'état très clairement
c'est un échec c'est une insurrection
desperados quoi un coach desperados avec
une extraordinaire incompétent
stratégique ce qu'on peut
bien sûr et on pourrait il pourrait se
dire qu'ils auraient eu plus d'intérêt à
attendre éventuellement une érosion de
la popularité de Lula et de prendre des
contacts informels avec des secteurs de
l'armée etc ils ont pas du tout fait ça
ils ont profité du fait que les réseaux
sociaux permettent notamment WhatsApp
télégram au Brésil permettent de faire
circuler très rapidement des
informations des appels à mobilisation
etc on s'imaginant peut-être que ça
allait réfléchir à déboulonner un état
qui est quand même assez même si la
démocratie est récente la dictature
militaire au Brésil est tombé dans les
années au milieu des années 80 mais des
Boulonnais un état qui est quand même
assez qui est malgré tout assez solide
on déboule pas un état de ce type là
avec quelques milliers d'individus bon
il faut des alliances avec des secteurs
importants de l'État en particulier dans
l'armée alors ils espéraient que
peut-être spontanément des secteurs de
l'armée allaient se placer de leur côté
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé à un
niveau je pense à individuel puisqu'on a
vu des policiers des des mondes des
forces de sécurité prendre des selfies
avec des bolsonaristes et un peu comme
on a vu au Capitole une certaine
complaisance une forte complaisance même
qui contrat d'ailleurs avec la la force
des des avec la violence des forces de
sécurité par exemple aux États-Unis face
à des mobilisations antiraciste quelques
mois auparavant bon une complaisance
vis-à-vis des trumpistes dans l'attaque
du capital et là des bolsonaris donc il
y a malgré tout des questions aussi à se
poser de ce côté là bon et dans le cadre
de bolsonaro contrairement à Trump il
avait une alliance avec avec des
secteurs de de de l'armée il y avait
beaucoup de militaires dans son
gouvernement bon donc je pense que ça
base effectivement est totalement toute
sa base que que bolsonaro avait mobilisé
hystérisé pendant des mois c'est dit que
peut-être l'armée allait y aller quoi et
aller prendre le pouvoir hein voilà ce
qui me semble quand même frappant dans
ces deux cas c'est la jonction entre des
groupes sans doute très clairement
fasciste dans le cas du capital c'était
les les prod boys centers des mouvements
suprémacistes etc et des gens pas
militants parfois tout à fait ordinaire
de la classe moyenne plutôt des
électeurs de la droite traditionnel mais
quoi mais nourri baigner dans le
complotisme une certaine façon qui sont
voilà qui sont infusées à se dispute
animé par une forme de alors paranoïa
raciale ou civilisationnel notamment
dans le cas états-unien ou effectivement
des théories confirationnistes autour du
covid de la pandémie etc mais un
deuxième si on remonte au 6 janvier 2021
donc il y a quasiment jour pour jour de
deux ans quoi il y avait aussi cette
impression que
c'est c'est les hommes principalement
ces femmes qui investissaient le
Capitole tu es pas vraiment là pour
prendre le pouvoir partir où ils sont à
l'intérieur il se filment enfin c'est ça
faisait un peu l'insurrection réseaux
sociaux je suis un je suis presque
volontairement caricatural mais pas
seulement quoi il y avait quand même
cette dimension c'est des coups d'État
mais qui sont pas vraiment fait pour
pour prendre le pouvoir est-ce que ils
ont écouté le président ça leur faisait
plaisir il manifester ils se faisait
plaisir certains se sentaient des
patriotes des défenseurs de la liberté
ils ont le sentiment qu'ils jouaient le
même rôle qu'en 1776 avec la déclaration
d'indépendance et ce qui était très
intéressant c'est que surtout ceux qui
ont été arrêtés alors ça ce sont les
plus violents et qui sont passés en
justice alors lorsqu'il y a eu un plaid
coupable on n'a pas trop d'informations
mais ce pour lesquels il y a eu jugement
qui ont déjà été jugés il y a eu des
peines de prison assez conséquentes et
d'or dans c'est intéressant les
premières pages du rapport de la
Commission du 6 janvier c'est une série
de citations de ces gens-là qui disait
j'ai eu tort j'ai écouté le Président
j'ai cru que je défendais la liberté
j'ai cru que je défendais les
institutions et je je me suis trompé et
ces gens là ils héritent de plusieurs
années de prison au-delà du folklore
il traquait par exemple le Nancy Pelosi
mon souvenirs
qui était de leur partie mais ça c'était
dû aussi à la violence
et il y avait une unité à l'extérieur du
Capitole donc ils étaient violents mais
c'était pas tout s'il y avait ceux qui
sont venus et puis qui ont été un peu
débordés mais qui ont été contente de
tout casser et ce qui prouve qu'il ne se
rendait pas compte c'est qu'il se
prenait en photo en selfie ce qui a
permis au FBI et au Département de la
Justice de les retrouver et de les
poursuivre et puis il y a ceux comme les
les au skippers des strippes 5 qui eux
ont échangé sur des messageries
confidentielles qui ont apporté des
armes non pas d'ici parce que c'est
interdit mais en Virginie tout à côté et
qui n'attendait que un petit signal
supplémentaire de Trump pour venir avec
leurs arbres et là passer à autre chose
s'il avait invoqué la loi sur
l'insurrection on va aller un peu plus
loin grâce à Steve Jourdain qui
justement a préparé est-ce que si j'ai
juste là oui bonsoir Steve bienvenue je
vous ai surprises c'était prévu un tout
petit peu plus tard mais c'est pas grave
tout va bien on s'arrange donc
effectivement on vous a demandé de
revenir sur sur ces événements du
Capitole avec le la question de l'action
de la justice aux États-Unis est-ce que
justice a été rendu ou non on est où bah
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que justice
est rendue de manière quasi quotidienne
aux États-Unis pour ces événements du
Capitole la preuve en chiffre Thomas au
moment où on parle près de et 1000
personnes ont été poursuivies pour leur
participation aux événements du 6
janvier 2021 938 citoyens américains ont
été accusés pour leur participation à la
tentative de coup d'État il y a un peu
de tout un des personnes qui sont
entrées dans le Capitole sans commettre
de violence il y a aussi les plus
excités les plus extrémistes qui s'était
organisé précisément pour empêcher le
transfert de pouvoir à jobiden cela sont
poursuivis pour sédition parmi les
accusés 532 ont été reconnus coupables
de par la justice 368 ont effectivement
été condamnés et environ 200 reçu une
peine de prison allant de 7 jours à 10
ans pour certains condamnés les juges
ont prononcé des peines un peu plus
clémentes comme des assignations à
résidence ou des heures de travail
d'intérêt général précision précisons
qu'il y a aujourd'hui encore des
centaines de personnes dans la nature
elles sont toujours recherchés par les
autorités américaines et alors qu'on
entre dans l'année 2023 140 personnes
ont d'ores et déjà reçues leur
convocation pour venir s'expliquer
devant la justice ils le font dans les
semaines qui viennent et Donald Trump
évidemment aussi cette question et de
notre dans cette histoire il doit être
poursuivi comme un criminel c'est la
conclusion d'une enquête parlementaire
qui a mobilisé pendant 18 mois des élus
de la Chambre des Représentants dont la
républicaine nice-chênée un certain
nombre de proches collaborateurs de
Donald Trump ont d'ailleurs témoigné
contre lui désormais le dossier est
entre les mains de la justice qui va
devoir décider si les poursuites seront
ou non engagées contre l'ancien
président lui de son côté comme comme
d'habitude est très offensif envers ses
accusateurs écoutez-le
c'est juste une chasse aux sorcières
sans raison enfin disons pour des
raisons politiques il ne devrait même
pas y avoir d'enquête et s'il y en a une
alors pourquoi il ne l'ont pas fait
auprès de tous les autres présidents qui
m'ont précédé par exemple Hillary
Clinton les bouches et Barack Obama
potenti Donald Trump pourrait être
poursuivi à plusieurs titres
obstructions d'une procédure officielle
conspiration contre les États-Unis
conspiration en vue de produire de
fausses déclarations encore incitations
ou aide à une insurrection voici les
quatre chefs d'accusation préconisés par
la commission d'enquête parlementaire à
faire à suivre évidemment merci Steve
Jordan dessine j'allais vous redonner la
parole je veux bien compléter parce
qu'en fait la vraie question dans tout
ça c'est l'impunité parce que pour le
moment c'est la démocratie à l'oeuvre
mais pourquoi elle est vrai responsables
ces Trump c'est le juriste isman qui a
été mentionné par la commission du 6 lui
aussi devrait faire l'objet d'un cul de
passion mais c'est Steve Banneux c'est
le chef de cabinet Marc mellows etc et
puis ce sont les élus les élus à la
Chambre qui juste avant devant la Maison
Blanche les inciter à monter sur le
Capitole ceux qui ont refusé de
certifier l'élection après l'assaut
contre le Capitole alors qu'ils avaient
bien vu ce qui se passait et certains
qui vont faire fait partie de la
nouvelle majorité des petits camarades
du nouveau speaker sont profondément
impliqués dans tout ça donc à partir du
moment où il y a la contagion du mauvais
exemple où il y a cet espèce Trump a
donné le mode d'emploi et tout le monde
se met alors là c'est d'abord le Brésil
mais il y aura d'autres mais en musique
le mode d'emploi de Trump il est
absolument essentiel qui pour mettre
face à d'habitude parce que sinon la
barre va devenir très haut tous les élus
vont se dire ah ben je peux faire ceci
il ne se passe rien donc c'est très
important qui est un certain nombre de
ces lampistes qui soient condamnés et
certains ont eu le choc de leur vie
quand ils croyait faire pas grand chose
et qu'ils ont hérité de 5 6 7 ans et
donc il y en a deux qui auraient presque
10 ans de prison mais ce sont les
proches de Trump et Trump alors ça je ne
sais pas si c'est faisable mais avec les
risques sont en train de peser le
ministre de la Justice et le procureur
spécial est-ce que ça va être le pays à
feu et à 100 si on incube Donald Trump
mais déjà si on pouvait moi
personnellement je suis déjà on pouvait
inculquer tous les élus du Congrès qui
ont propagé le mensonge et qui ont à la
violence le 6 déjà je trouve que ça
ferait du progrès alors sur la question
des sanctions justement je vous propose
d'écouter tout de suite ce que ce que
disait le président Lula quand il est
arrivé sur les lieux de cette
insurrection
s
il faut que ces personnes soient punies
de manière exemplaire que ces personnes
soient punies de manière à ce que plus
personne n'ose avec le drapeau national
sur le dos ou en portant le t-shirt de
l'équipe brésilienne prétendre être
nationaliste prétendre être brésilien
faire ce qu'ils ont fait aujourd'hui
cela ne s'était jamais produit
auparavant
vous qui connaissez bien Lula il est
c'est plutôt quelqu'un de calme
habituellement c'est quel type de
caractère
relaxer etc et lierre je le but enragé
jamais vu il est arrangé mais il est
plus coupé il est vivement c'est pas
Louis de la façon d'être
sympa bonne façon d'être il est en
conciliateur
mais dans ce cas là c'est clair que lui
là aussi que c'est un conciliateur d'ici
a compris ils savent qu'il peut pourra
pas concilier la question de l'impunité
la question de la pollution de chaque
arrivé c'est crucial au Brésil il a ses
particules de seul pays de l'Amérique du
Sud où il a eu des
dictatures militaires partout mais le
seul pays où il n'y a jamais eu de
pollution pour les militaires qui ont
les coupables aussi des des disparitions
des centaines d'assassinats des milliers
de torturés etc et donc il y a peut-être
ce sentiment d'impunité qui est un peu
présent rémanent dans dans l'esprit de
certains et ça c'était l'histoire du
Brésil et on fait avant de ce qui s'est
passé hier on peut y avoir une
discussion quoi faire avec bossoir
bonsoir reparti on fait ce reposer aux
États-Unis en Floride et aussi parce que
il a des des problèmes judiciaires n'est
plus aussi donc sera jugé par la justice
comment commune et il a plaisir
casserole le problème mais ça c'est
encore plus grave de ce que du passé et
donc il avait un chef articulation
souterrain pour des bons il faut pas les
mettre en prison parce que ça pourrait
créer une situation mais ça c'est fini
maintenant il a comment dire le message
aussi souvent
poursuivre boursement le sien parce que
c'est que c'est passé c'est vraiment
trop et en fait ils ont déjà arrêté sur
plus de 300 on est déjà arrivé à 12 ans
et donc qui sont bon pas maintenant quoi
en garde à vue et après on verra
qu'est-ce qu'elle va se passer mais la
question de l'impunité c'est-à-dire
faire justice pour que pour ceux qui se
passait pour hier mais comme dans le
cadre aux États-Unis qui a financé tout
ça parce que on parle des milliers de
personnes qui sont restés pendant des
semaines dans des campements
on fait rien qui est demandé
l'intervention militaire qui a payé pour
ça bon on peut se réuni à Brasilia
des milliers de personnes en face de la
de en fait de comment centrale de
l'armée mais aussi dans plusieurs
capitales du pays et donc pendant des
semaines de semaine des milliers des
milliers de personnes donc quelqu'un a
failli quelqu'un a financé il a surtout
des business main afin de de monde aux
affaires de la demande des affaires de
l'agrobisme et surtout de la région de
centre ouest du Brésil qui est très
puissant de prendre une économique et on
rejoint aussi ou bossunar a eu plus de
60% 70% de voix et qui ont comme ils ont
pasceptés la défaite électorale ils ont
décidé bon il faut faire autre chose et
enfin comme on dit arrondi avant les
collègues ils ont ils sont pas réussi à
gagner des fois de façon démocratique
donc l'idée c'est renverser le
les militaires jusque là ils ont rien
fait mais de façon positive mais de
façon négative ils ont rien fait
si on revient on vient d'écouter Lula le
pouvoir de Lula est-ce qu'il est
forcément fragilisé par ce coup d’état
ou peut-être au contraire renforcé
puisque c'est un échec je dirais que
tout dépendra de sa politique dans les
mois et années à venir c'est à dire s'il
arrive à alors qu'il a une coalition
très hétérogène politiquement donc ça va
être compliqué si il arrive à
véritablement changer les choses pour le
mieux pour une majorité du peuple
brésilien il peut avoir quelque chose
d'assez une majorité assez solide
majorité sociale je veux dire pas
simplement parlementaire si comme on
peut le craindre il est bloqué dans ces
initiatives pour améliorer les choses
notamment socialement parce qu'il y a un
énorme problème de pauvreté au Brésil
actuellement avec beaucoup de gens qui
ont faim bon voilà c'est ça la réalité
et donc s'il n'y parvient pas les mêmes
causes produisant les mêmes effets on
peut on n'est pas libéré du bolsonarisme
même y compris 100 bolsonaro ou de même
de la même manière qu'on n'est pas
libéré du 30isme même éventuellement
sans Trump ce sont des des personnages
qui ont construit une base sociale et
une base capable de se mobiliser et elle
a montré à une échelle qui pour
l'instant reste trop petite pour
véritablement
gagner sur un coup d'état on voilà il
aurait fallu des dizaines voire des
centaines de milliers de de personnes
mobilisées plutôt que quelques milliers
mais disons que
c'est pas le chant du signe pour moi en
tout cas mon hypothèse personnellement
c'est que c'est pas le chant du signe
c'est plutôt malheureusement peut-être
une répétition générale et là les si
vous voulez les cas historiques il y en
a il y en a pléthore dans
l'entre-deux-guerre le 6 février 34 en
France le push de la brasserie en
Allemagne en 23 qui était qui était
folklorique d'une certaine manière la
marche Rome était ratée c'était d'un
point de vue militaire c'était
complètement raté et si ça a gagné c'est
parce que Mussolini avait des alliances
avait réussi à à bâtir des alliances qui
l'ont rend disons incontournable et le
roi l'a appelé à former un gouvernement
ce que je veux dire c'est que dans les
années à venir tous ces toute cette
mouvance qui se coagule qui se
cristallise cette mouvance fasciste ou
néo fasciste si on veut elle ne va pas
disparaître de la scène la crise sociale
est là le capitalisme est clairement en
paralysie dans l'impasse
la démocratie est faible dans bien des
pays la gauche est très faible ne
parvient pas à paraître comme une
alternative réelle à la cieux dans la
situation donc c'est mouvance vont
continuer à prospérer d'une certaine
manière aussi bien d'un point de vue
électoral institutionnel mais aussi dans
la rue et c'est ça que c'est ça le c'est
à quel point c'est courant maintenant
prennent des initiatives beaucoup plus
audacieuses ils vont à l'assaut des
lieux de pouvoir j'ai on n'aurait pas
imaginé ça il y a 10 15 ou 20 ans c'est
c'est assez imaginable et c'est pour ça
que j'ai cité les quatre pays et pas des
petits pays des pays du centre du
capitalisme mondial États-Unis Brésil
france-it pas France Allemagne
excusez-moi
je voudrais revenir sur le rôle de la
police et le rôle de l'armée on va
ouvrir ce chapitre dans dans ce débat
John Carlos Ouma est-ce que la police a
été d'une certaine façon complice
donc les Brésiliens c'est un pays
fédéral la police dans chaque État
dépend du gouverneur brésilien
surferal merci d'un gouverneur qui a
fait été suspendu de son mandat pendant
3 mois ce matin pour les mêmes jugent la
course au prime que c'est la bête noire
donc ça veut dire pour bien comprendre
le le pouvoir fédé enfin local à
Brasilia le oui d'accord et le
gouverneur était bolsonariste ah oui
c'est bien ça on est bien d'accord de
sécurité donc ce que celui qui contrôle
directement la police et de ce fédéral
et a été ministre ça a été un ministre
de la Justice je crois de Bolson
peut-être que je me trompe mais je dis
ça
j'aime bien rappelé et donc lui est hier
même a été on fait maintenant il a
mandat d'arrêt contre lui mais donc la
police n'a rien fait pour empêcher
empêcher tout ce qui s'est passé et
c'est intéressant parce que si vous
connaissez brésilia cette manifeste
femme manifestation c'est Van dalle ils
ont marché pendant 8 km de leur
campement de en faire
comment de l'armée jusque à la place de
trois pouvoirs 8 km le prix presque 2h
pour le faire avec ton intervenir
regardez sympa rien fait mais donc ça
d'un côté la police s'appelle police
militaire toute l'histoire et après
l'armée parce que alors l'armée l'armée
je vais vous donner la parole je vais
vous allez pouvoir continuer là pouvoir
continuer la démonstration mais je vous
propose un autre témoignage celui d'un
journaliste ancien correspondant en
Amérique latine qui était chez nos
confrères de France 24 et qui justement
analyse le rôle de l'armée peut-être les
tentatives de des bolsonaris pour créer
encore plus de liens avec l'armée on
l'écoute beaucoup ont estimé que si les
48 heures de silence de jaillir
bolsonaro après sa défaite à l'élection
présidentielle ont été un temps où il a
il a tenté de négocier il a tenté de
sonder la volonté des militaires de le
suivre ou non dans une démarche de coûts
et visiblement il a reçu une fin de
non-recevoir des militaires plus
soucieux de préserver les acquis qu'ils
ont obtenu pendant la présidente de
jaillir
busaner dans une tentative de coût qui
n'aurait été toléré
certainement pas au Brésil et
certainement pas ailleurs aux États-Unis
en Europe et dans les autres pays donc
si c'est peut-être vous n'êtes pas
d'accord mais ça veut dire qu'on a une
armée brésilienne en tout cas on va pas
faire La Malga mais une partie de
l'armée brésilienne qui est bolsonaris
et quoi dans une situation un peu
d'attente qui attendent
hier il est Vendin les ont envahi les
paliers présidentielles ce qu'on dit
comme ceci était en train de rentrer à
l'Élysée et casser tout bon il a deux
unités d'élite de la de l'armée de
l'armée de terre mais qui sont chargés
que de la Défense le palais présidentiel
ils ont rien fait ils sont disparu et ça
donc l'armée il y a en chaîne de
commande c'est pas que les argent a
décidé bouffe maintenant je parle à la
campagne non donc il y a eu sans doute
quelqu'un donner lors de rien faire par
défendre les paris présidentielles le
point de vue et là c'est l'armée du
Brésil c'est pas l'armée de de l'état de
et donc je pense que les collègues ont
les confrères j'étais je suis ancien
journaliste moi-même donc et il a raison
parce que Lula a nommé comme un ministre
de la Défense donc en théorie le chef
des forces armées et en politicien
plutôt en véritable de la politique qui
ont fait un copain de tous très copain
de boursoramaro merci de Lula c'était le
Conseil José moussu et que il a fait il
est un copain de ministère le militaire
sont d'accord elle était d'accord pour
avoir Louis communiste de France et
qu'est-ce que c'est passe il avait plus
de 8000 militaires dans le gourmands des
boursoramaro oui il a nommé des
militaires partout dans le gouvernement
c'était un gourmand militaire dans
l'administration pas dans le
gouvernement dans les dans les
ministères d'accord dans les différents
ministres dans les différents ministère
mais aussi que dans les entre les
ministres plusieurs en deux minutes
c'était des militaires
et donc non mais démocratiquement
des militaires dans l'administration
brésilien qui pendant la distincteur et
ils ont pas été virés par les nouveaux
gourmands pas encore d'accord donc je
pense que oui ils ont essayé de faire un
accord et la corne n'a pas vraiment
marché mais alors Hugo pas établer un
peu abordé tout à l'heure pourquoi
cette tentative de coup d'état alors que
il y a pas de soutien des militaires
c'était vous pouvez à l'échec d'une
certaine façon oui je pense que en fait
ces mouvements là trumpiz bolsonaristes
et d'autres dans le monde sont dans une
phase de développement sont dans une
phase j'aurais tendance à dire infantile
et donc dans cette phase infantile ils
font preuve d'une incompétence
stratégique à peu près totale
mais là encore je voudrais revenir ça ne
veut pas dire que on est voilà vous
dites c'est pas le chant du signe c'est
peut-être la mort
qui va grandir et surtout qui va devenir
sans doute plus habile dans sa capacité
à nouer des alliances à choisir le bon
moment pour attaquer parce qu'en fait là
c'est dans les termes de du grand
penseur italien antoniogrammeci c'est un
peu l'articulation problématique entre
la guerre de position dans les
institutions faire rentrer des
militaires dans les ministères etc et
puis la guerre de mouvement et là d'une
certaine manière le moment où ils ont
enclenché la guerre de mouvement était
leur force n'était pas prête leur
soutien n'était pas là donc c'était un
mauvais moment c'est clairement une
mauvaise stratégie en terme en terme
militaire en quelque sorte alors un
désigne voulait intervenir et je vous
donne la parole juste après en fait ce
qui m'a frapper là quand j'ai entendu ce
qui se passait au Brésil c'est quand
même le fait que aux États-Unis pendant
trois heures il ne s'est rien passé on a
laissé tout le monde tout détruire et au
Brésil c'est 4 heures donc quand il se
passe ça ça veut dire qu'il y a des
complicités et que les forces de police
les différentes aux États-Unis c'est la
police du Capitole la police de la
capitale d'ici etc et on a vu ensuite
que ils étaient noyautés il y a parmi
les éléments de ces
beaucoup d'extrême droite beaucoup de
gens qui appartiennent à ces groupes
violents ou ce qui peut etc et puis pas
mal de suprémacistes blancs et donc
deux ans d'enquête va se recule aux
États-Unis permet de dire aujourd'hui et
tout de suite on s'est rendu compte
aussi du deux poids de mesure que vous
avez bien souligné lorsqu'il s'agissait
de combattre les les manifestations
parfois un petit peu violentes des Black
lives matters là ils tapait sans retenue
mais là c'était des petits camarades il
cassait le Capitole on les laissait
faire alors c'est sûr que ça n'empêche
pas que des membres de la capitale de la
police du Capitole ont été blessées
certains sont morts donc c'est pas tout
le monde mais le mot que j'emploie c'est
noyota j'ai un noyotage des forces de
police et des forces militaires et ça on
ne sait pas ce que ça va donner à moyen
terme
c'est bien faire ça que vous avez fait
l'un des différences et comme il n'y a
pas de soutien internationaux possibles
et ça c'est quelque chose la Maison
Blanche a dit depuis le début où ils
font il faut il faut faire arriver tous
les messages aux militaires brésiliens
il n'aura pas de coups de temps il y
aura aucun soutien et je voulais faire
il aura des conséquences donc ça c'est
en langage que les militaires en général
mais les militaires en Amérique latiné
au Brésil ils vont compris très bien
c'est pas c'est ça je pense qui a sauvé
hier de la possibilité que quelque chose
commençait un peu de façon bizarre pour
être pour se transformer d'un coup
d'État avec des temps
dans les rues de Brasilia une telle
attaque était possible en France on va
essayer de répondre à cette question
avec vous Mathieu mais d'abord je vous
propose d'entendre ce que ce matin sur
France Inter
du groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée
à pas un micro climat j'allais dire qui
protège l'Union européenne ou qui
protège donc la France par rapport au
tentatives populistes et encore une fois
on a au départ des parties qui étaient
arrivés de manière démocratique au
pouvoir la question c'est qu'à partir du
moment où l'extrême droite arrive au
pouvoir quand elle doit le quitter parce
qu'elle est battue elle refuse de le
quitter avec des mouvements qui ont été
fomentés vraisemblablement par bolsonaro
par ses partisans sont pas des
mouvements spontanés qui aujourd'hui se
sont se sont exprimés au Brésil Mathieu
de telle débordement sont-ils possibles
en France il faut rester prudent bien
sûr mais jusqu'à présent faut le dire
aussi le débat politique a beau être
hyper antagonisé depuis quelques temps
ça n'a jamais débouché sur ce genre de
contestation électorale par la force on
a parlé du 6 février 34 qui était ça
remonte quand même à longtemps les
violences abrasia d'ailleurs elles ont
été condamnées par
de la classe politique française de
Jordan Bardella pour le rassemblement
national Emmanuel Bompard pour les
insoumis lors des deux derniers scrutins
présentiels toutefois ce scénario a
quand même été envisagé en 2017 on était
dans un contexte qui était encore très
marqué par des attentats terroristes y
compris trois jours avant le premier
tour et bien une note des renseignements
généraux faisait le point sur les
risques d'attentat bien sûr mais aussi
elle détaillait les possibles
débordements en cas de qualification
pour le second tour de Marine Le Pen ou
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans ce cas des
manifestations sont envisagées avec une
quasi certitude écrivait des enquêteurs
des mouvements d'extrême gauche plus ou
moins implantés cherchons ensemble une
doute organiser des manifestations dont
certaines pour entraîner des troubles
sérieux à ajouter les fonctionnaires de
RG en 2022 dans un contexte qui était
cette fois-ci marqué par la montée du
complotisme on sortait quand même de
deux années de covid avec tout ce qu'on
a pu connaître cette fois-ci les
policiers se sont intéressés à des
postes relayés sur les réseaux sociaux
dénonçant un système au départ c'était
dénonciation d'un système de
manipulation de vote par Emmanuel Macron
McKinsey le soutien d'une entreprise
américaine bref n'importe quoi mais ce
qui inquiétait les enquêteurs ce sont
surtout les appels à ne pas se laisser
voler l'élection parce que ce slogan là
ne pas se laisser voler l'élection c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui commence à
préparer les esprits pour pour des pour
des coûts par la suite en gros les
enquêteurs redoutaient le passage de la
défiance qui marquait l'élection des
finances par rapport au public des
Français par rapport au sondage des
finances par rapport aux résultats à la
violence comme au capital et c'est pas
arrivé non heureusement oui mais la
crainte elle reste là parce qu'en France
il faut le dire aussi la situation a
changé depuis cinq ans vous en disiez un
mot pour l'Europe en France il y a quand
même des choses qu'on change avant les
lieux de pouvoir ils étaient pris pour
cible pour défendre une cause les
agriculteurs ils allaient déposer du
lisier ou des versets du lait devant les
préfectures pour protester contre la
politique agricole commune en 2018 on a
eu un incendie de la préfecture du
Puy-en-Velay je parle pas du saccage
avec le triomphe durant le mouvement des
gilets jaunes et puis on a eu des appels
à être destituer Emmanuel Macron tout ça
c'est inquiété les forces de l'ordre car
là c'était les symboles du pouvoir en
tant que qui était mise en cause avec
des gens qui voulaient leur renversement
qui voulaient la destitution l'un des
initiateurs du mouvement Eric Drouet qui
appelait à rentrer dans l'Elysée lors de
l'acte 4 des gilets jaunes d'ailleurs
fait l'objet d'une enquête à l'époque
pour provocation à la commission d'un
crime ou d'un délit et organisation
d'une manifestation illicite il a été
par la suite relaxé en appelant rappelle
qu'en France une insurrection c'est
définit dans le code pénal c'est
constituer un mouvement résurrectionnel
toute violence collective de nature à
mettre en péril les institutions de la
République ou apporter atteinte à
l'intégrité du territoire national et le
fait de diriger un mouvement
insurrectionnel c'est puni de la
détention criminelle à perpétuité et de
750 000 euros d'amende donc on n'est pas
dans on ne voit pas ça en France mais
quand même pensons au ferment je pense
juste à quelque chose et je termine
là-dessus quand vous voyez les sondages
qui montent avec des Français qui
demandent de plus en plus enfin ils sont
plus en plus nombreux à demander des
régimes autoritaires quand vous voyez au
lendemain d'une élection des gens qui
délégitimes l'élection du président élu
en disant il a été mal élu c'est pas un
vrai président cinq minutes quand vous
voyez les résultats en l'occurrence
certains selon les bords tout le tout le
complotisme toutes les fake news qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux mais
évidemment ce ne sont pas les événements
mais ça peut constituer les ferments
Hugo paletta votre réaction là-dessus
vous l'avez déjà un peu évoqué tout à
l'heure mais c'est vrai qu'on a Mathieu
vient de les cités deux exemples
d'élections présidentielles ou Marine Le
Pen a été battue aux alentours il y a
pas eu de mouvement insurrectionnel ou
de ou de remise en cause violente je dis
bien violente du résultat d'élection
ouais à ce stade
les mouvances de l'extrême droite
violente de rue sont relativement
faibles si on compare la France à
l'Allemagne par exemple c'est plutôt x
10 c'est après les chiffres des services
de renseignement plutôt 3000 en France
et 30 000 en Allemagne mais je tiens à
souligner le fait qu'il y a de plus en
plus d'attentats d'extrême droite qui
sont formés qui sont déjoués par les
services de police 10 depuis 2017 et
donc moi ce que je crains le plus c'est
pas tant enfin ça peut arriver des
manifestations du type Brasilia ou
capital etc que des actes d'individus
qui paraissent isolés qui le souvent ne
le sont pas n'oublions pas que brave it
par exemple avait été membre pendant 7
ans de la principale organisation
d'extrême droite norvégienne avant de
commettre ces crimes plusieurs dizaines
de meurtres de jeunes militants
socialistes de gauche
donc ce qu'on appelle parfois des loups
solitaires en sommet prenant sur le fait
que les loups solitaires sont récemment
des individus qui tombent du ciel qui se
sont auto-intoxiqués sur internet ce
sont souvent des gens qui ont été
travaillés y compris qui ont été parfois
membres d'organisation mais qui font
partie d'un milieu plus large milieu
idéologique parfois milieu organisé
organise avec des organisations derrière
et c'est je crois que à la fois en
France mais au niveau européen et au
niveau mondial on a aussi ce phénomène
là aux États-Unis qui cohabitent en fait
avec le développement de mouvance
d'extrême droite et de mobilisation
factueuse voilà des des actes
terroristes en fait d'extrêmement comme
on l'a vu par ailleurs rue d'Enghien il
y a très peu de temps à Paris en plein
Paris la deuxième vie interdit moi j'ai
le sentiment alors soit nous sommes en
retard soit le système français mieux
protégé d'abord à la différence des
États-Unis pour le moment il n'y a pas
de mouvement large qui explique que nos
élections sont frauduleuses alors c'est
peut-être dû au mode de scrutin
finalement on met son papier on peut
tous être allé observer à les compter
les bulletins de vote donc ça c'est
important j'ai le sentiment aussi en
partie grâce au régulation européenne
qu'il y a un petit peu moins de
désinformations et en particulier des
informations politiques sur l'élection
etc en France qu'il y en a aux
États-Unis et sans doute au Brésil donc
il y a des petits éléments sur lesquels
si on veut empêcher ce genre de choses
il faut peut-être essayer de jouer de
façon à ce que les choses restent à ce
niveau en France au lieu de de déraper
comme ça a été le cas aux États-Unis au
Brésil on parlait complotisme c'est
aussi un
des Terreaux de du bolsonarisme et
évidemment au Brésil il faut il faut le
rappeler
et en fait les réseaux sociaux il faut
pas démoniser rien ce sont des outils
mais évidemment ça dépend de ce qu'on
met dedans
en 2018 a été élu sans presque campagne
électorale et parce qu'il n'avait pas la
télé rien regarder de soutien donc fait
sa mobilisation
c'était la mobilisation de sa base c'est
donner sur les réseaux sociaux et
seulement
est continué à se mobiliser sur les
réseaux sociaux mais de façon de plus en
plus bizarres pas sur l'extrémisme avec
des choses vraiment de n'importe quoi et
des théoriques de conspiration donc
comment aux États-Unis mais l'équivalent
là-bas et des choses qui de gens
rationnelles de moi c'est pas possible
mais non ça ça a bien marché et donc il
y a un processus radicalisation j'estime
à partir de ce certain sondage qui ont
été faits qui il y a on peut calculer
entre 20 et 25% de l'électorat
brésilienne qui aujourd'hui
presque 50 donc la différence était très
limité donc la conspiration sur les
résultats électoral mais et pas tout ce
qui ont voté pour bossunars sont des
radicaux Bor sonaristes
sont pas prêtes à faire le livration de
la place de trois pouvoirs entre 20 et
25 % de l'électorat que oui apparemment
son constat essai et normes c'est énorme
et ça rejoint ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure c'est la collections qu'on se
pose sur la suite du mandat de Lula
merci beaucoup laissé ces trois quarts
d'heure sont passés à toute vitesse qui
est toujours bon signe c'était
passionnant de recevoir sur sur ce
plateau je vais rappeler le titre de vos
livres les États-Unis et la démocratie
publie aux éditions l'Harmattan je les
ai fait dans le désordre voilà et puis
la nouvelle internationale de la
fasciste c'est votre niveau merci encore
d'être venu sur ce